what was the philosophy
the journey that took you to becoming a
buddhist monk
and what uh what were
what did you learn about life what did
you take away from that experience how
did you return back
to harvard and uh the world that's
unlike that experience i imagine yeah
well i was at dartmouth at the time
um uh well i went to sri lanka i was
already pretty interested in developing
countries and sort of under-resourced
areas
and uh i was doing a lot of engineering
work and i went there but i was also
starting to think maybe health was
something of interest
um and uh
so i went to sri lanka because i had a
long interest in
buddhism as well just kind of interested
in it as a thing
which aspect of the philosophy attracted
you i would say that the
thing that interested me most was um
was really this idea of kind of a
butterfly effect of like
uh you know what you do now
has ripple effects that extend out
beyond
what you can possibly imagine um
both in your own life and in other
people's lives and in some ways buddhism
has
none in some ways in a pretty deep way
buddhism has that as part of its
underlying philosophy in terms of
rebirth and sort of
that your actions today propagate
uh to others but also propagate to to
sort of
uh what might happen in in your circle
of what's called samsara and rebirth and
um i don't i don't know that i subscribe
fully to this idea that uh we are reborn
uh which always was a little bit of a of
a
debate internally i suppose when i was a
monk
but it but it has always been it was
that and then it was also meditation
um at the time i was a fairly elite
rower i was
you know rowing at the national level
and um
and rowing to me was very meditative it
was
um you know just there's
even if you're on a boat with other
people it's i mean on the one hand it's
like the extreme of like a team sport
but it's also
the extreme sort of focus and
concentration that requires
that's required of it and so i was
always really into just meditative
type of things i was doing a lot of
pottery too which was also very
meditative and
and so buddhism just kind of really
really there are a lot of things about
meditating
that just uh appealed and so i moved to
sri lanka
planning to only be there for a couple
of months um
but then i was shadowing in this medical
clinic and there was this physician who
was just really
i mean it's just kind of a horrible
situation um frankly this guy was
trained
decades earlier he was an older
physician and he was still just
practicing like these fairly barbaric
approaches to medicine because he
had he was a rural town and he just
didn't have a lot of um
he didn't have any updated training
frankly and so you know i just remember
this like girl
came in with like shrapnel in her hand
and his solution was to like
air it out and so he was like without
even
numbing her hand he was uh uh like
cutting it open more okay with this idea
that like the more
oxygen and and stuff you know and it
just
i think there was something about all of
this and i was already talking to these
monks at the time each
i would be in this clinic in the morning
and i'd go
and uh my idea was to teach english to
these monks in the evening
uh turned out i'm a really bad english
teacher
so they just taught they they allowed me
just to sit with them
and and meditate and they were teaching
me more about buddhism than i could have
possibly taught them about english or
being an american or something um and uh
and and so i just slowly i just couldn't
take i
like couldn't handle being in that
clinic so more and more i just started
moving to
you know spending more and more time at
this monastery and then after about two
months i was supposed to come back to
the states and i decided i didn't want
to
so i moved to this monastery in the
mountains
primarily because i didn't have the
money to like just keep living
so living in a monastery is free yeah
and so i
moved there and just started meditating
more and more and then months went by
and
and i it just really gravitated
i i gravitated to the whole to the whole
notion of it i mean it became
it sounds strange but you know
meditating almost just like anything
that you've put your mind to
became exciting you know it became like
there weren't enough hours in the day to
meditate
and i would do it for you know 18 hours
a day 15 hours a day
uh just sit there and you and like
i mean i hate sleeping anyway but i
wouldn't want to go to sleep because
i felt like i didn't accomplish what i
needed to accomplish in meditation that
day
which is so strange because there is no
end you know but it was always but there
are these
uh there are these steps that happen
during meditation that are very
prescribed in a way
buddha talked about them you know and
these are ancient writings which exist i
mean the writings are real they're
thousands of years old now and um
you know so whether it was buddha
writing them or whoever you know
there are lots of different people
who've contributed to the to these
writings over the years
and um but they're very prescribed
and they um they tell you what you're
going to go through
and i didn't really focus too much on
them
i read a little bit about them but your
mind really does when you actually start
meditating
at that level like not an hour here and
there but like truly just spending your
days meditating
it becomes kind of like this other world
where it becomes exciting
and uh and you're actively working
you're actively
meditating not just kind of trying to
quiet things that's sort of just the
first stage
of trying to get your mind to focus most
people never get past that first stage
especially in our culture
could you briefly summarize what's
waiting beyond the stage of just
quieting the mind
is yeah it's hard for me to imagine that
there's
something that could be described as
exciting
on there yeah it's it's an interesting
question so i would say um
so the first thing the first step is
truly just to like be able to close your
eyes
focus on your breath and not have other
thoughts enter into your mind
that alone is just so hard to do like
i couldn't do it now if i wanted um
but i could then and um but once you get
past that stage
you start entering into like all these
other you go through kind of
i went through this like pretty trippy
stage which is a little bit euphoric
um where you just kind of start not
hallucinating i mean it wasn't like some
crazy thing that would happen in a movie
where
but definitely just weird you start
getting to the stage where
um uh you you're able to quiet your mind
for so
long for hours at a time that um like
for me i started
uh getting really excited about this
idea of mindfulness
which is part of part buddhism in
general but it's part of terabot and
buddhism in particular for this
in this way which was um you take
you start focusing on your daily
activities whether that's sipping a cup
of tea
or walking or
you know sweeping around uh i lived in
on this mountainside in this cottage
thing it's built into the rock and
um you know so every morning i would
wake up early and sweep around it and
stuff because that's just what we did
and you start to you meditate on all
those activities
and one of the things that was so
exciting which sounds completely
ridiculous now
was just um almost learning
about your daily activities in ways that
you never would have thought about
before
so what is entire what what's what's
involved with like picking up this glass
of water you know
if i said okay i'm just gonna pick i'm
going to take a drink of water
to me right now it's a single activity
right you just
but um during a during meditation
it's not a single activity it's a whole
series of activities of like little
engineering feats
um and feelings and it's it's gripping
the water
and it's feeling that the glass is cold
and it's lifting and it's moving and
dragging and dragging
and and you start to learn a whole new
language of life
and that to me was like this really
exhilarating thing
that um it was an exhilarating component
of meditation that
there was never enough time it's kind of
like learning a new computer language
like it gets really exciting when you
start coding and
all these new things you can do you you
learn how to
much to experience life in a much richer
way and so you never run out of ways to
go deeper and deeper and deeper in the
way you experience even just the
the drinking of the glass of water
that's that's exactly right and what
becomes kind of exhilarating is
um you start to be able to predict
things that you never
or i don't even know if prediction's
right word but i always think of the
matrix you know or
where um i forget who it was somebody
was shooting at
neo and he like leans backwards and he
dodges the bullets
um you know in some ways when you start
breaking every little action that your
hands do or that your feet do or
your body does down into all these
little actions that make up one what we
normally think of
as an action all of a sudden you can
start to see things almost in slow
motion
i like to think of it very much like
language
the first time somebody hears a foreign
uh it sounds really fast usually you
don't hear the spaces between words
and um and it just sounds like
just like a stream of conscious and it
just sounds like a stream of noises if
you've never heard the language before
and as you learn the language
you hear clear breaks between words and
it starts to gain context and and all of
a sudden like that what
once sounded very fast slows down
and it has meaning that's our whole life
well there's this whole language
happening that we don't speak generally
but if you start to speak it and if you
start to learn it and you start to say
hey i'm picking up this glass is
actually 18 little movements
then all of a sudden like it becomes
extremely exciting
and exhilarating to just just breathe
you know breathing alone in the rise and
fall of your abdomen or the
way the air pushes in and out of your
nose becomes
almost interesting um and what's really
neat is
is the world just starts slowing down
and
um i'll never forget that feeling and
it's the if there was one
euphoric feeling from meditation i want
to gain back
um but i don't think i could without
really meditating like that again and i
don't think i will
um was this like slow motion of the
world
it was finding the spaces between all
the movements the same way that the
spaces between all the words happen
and then it almost gives you this new
appreciation for everything you know
it's like
it was really amazing and so i think um
it came to an abrupt end though when the
tsunami hit i was there in the
indian ocean tsunami hit in 2004
and it was like this dichotomy of being
a monk and
and you know just meditating in this
extraordinary
place um and then the tsunami hits and
kills 40 000 people in a few minutes on
the coast of this really small little
country in sri lanka
and um you know then i i
it like my whole world of being a monk
came crashing down
uh when i go to the coast
and i i mean that was just a devastating
visual sight an emotional sight but
the strangest thing happened which was
that everyone just wanted me to stay as
a monk
you know people in that culture um they
wanted to
the monks largely fled from the
coastlines of those
you know and um and so then there i was
and people wanted me to be a monk they
wanted me to stay on the coast but be a
monk
and not help like not help in the in the
way that i considered helping
uh they wanted me just to keep
meditating so they could bring me donna
like
like offerings and get and have their
sort of karmic responsibilities
um uh attended to as well and so
uh that was really bizarre to me it was
like how could i possibly just sit
around
while all these people half of
everyone's family just died
and so in any case i stopped being a
monk and i moved to this refugee camp
and lived there for
another six months or so and uh and just
stayed there uh not as a monk
um but tried to raise some money from
the u.s and tried to like
i didn't know what i was doing frankly i
was 22
and uh and i don't think i appreciated
at the time how much of a role i was
having in the in that
community's life uh but
it's taken me a long many years to
process all of this since then but uh
i would say it's what put me into the
public health world seeing living in
that refugee camp
and that difference that happened you
know from being a monk to
being in this devastating environment um
just really changed my whole view of
what sort of
why i was existing i suppose
you